Just three months old today, Prince George's christening will take place tomorrow...
...at 3 PM, British standard time in a 45-minute ceremony...
...at the Chapel Royal in St. James's Palace.
The Duke and Duchess of Cambridge's choice of venue is a break from tradition.
William, Prince Charles and the Queen's christening took place at Buckingham Palace...
...while Prince Harry was at St. George's Chapel at Windsor Castle.
The Chapel Royal is where Princess Diana's coffin was placed for her family...
...to pay their last respects before her funeral in 1997.
Prince George who is third in line to the throne...
...will be christened by the Archbishop of Canterbury, the Most Reverend Justin Willoughby.
The event will be private, attended by only close family and the baby's godparents...
...who have yet to be named.
While the public won't be part of the intimate family affair,...
...they can take part by purchasing a christening coin from the Royal Mint.
History will be made as Prince George of Cambridge becomes the first royal baby...
...to be honored with a set of three commemorative coins...
...with a design that has the blessing of William, Kate and the Queen.